Anthony: Scientists have stopped light and
trapped it in a crystal for a full minute.
Show offs.
Anthony: Anthony here for Dnews and look!
I've set out some candy, and I trapped a Sourcefed!
Hello lady Sourcefed.
Lee: I'm Lee Newton, or just Lee.
Anthony: Lady Sourcefed everybody!
Lee: Anyway, light thinks it's pretty impressive.
It gets to be a particle and wave at the same
time.
And it travels at the speed of around 300,000
meters/second.
Which means it can get to the moon and back
20 times in a single minute.
Until we trap it in a crystal for that minute,
Zod style, who's impressive now, light?
Anthony: A German team from the University
of Darmstadt, stopped particles of light for
a full minute using crystals and lasers,
which is the most 80's scifi thing I think
I've ever heard of.
So you've got an opaque crystal and its atoms
are all vibrating around, like they do.
And at any time, those atoms could be in a
couple of different states.
And the team fired lasers into the crystal
to make those atoms exist in a quantum super
position.
Lee: Which is the worst James Bond move.
Anthony: Which is a mix of those two states.
In that super position, the opaque crystal
became transparent to certain kinds of light.
So they fired a second laser into the now
transparent crystal, and it passed through.
And then they shut off the first laser and
whoops!
Crystal is opaque again.
And the particles of light from the second
beam are trapped in the crystal.
Lee: Now this isn't the first time we put
light in its place either.
A previous experiment by a German team, two
years ago, used super cold atoms to stop light
for a couple of seconds.
Anthony: Why do this?
Basically, so the other scientists fear and
respect you.
But also, if we trap light, we can use it
to store and retrieve data.
And that's a big deal because currently, computers
store data as a 1 or a 0 and they process
that data 1 bit at a time.
Lee: Because light can exist in different
states at once, we could store data in a 1
or a 0 both at once.
Meaning computers could crunch data much faster
and work on multiple problems at the same
time.
It's called quantum computing.
And if we can make it work cheaply and reliably,
we'll be sending and receiving incredibly
secure data and processing it at speeds completely
unreachable by today's computers.
Anthony: Sexy, secure Snapchats at the speed
of light everybody!
That's all I can think to use it for.
Lee: I know.
It's all we could ever do.
You know what I think?
So many puppy pictures all at once.
Secure puppy safe and secure puppy pictures.
Anthony: Now you guys might be wondering,
"Hey, what's Lee Newton doing here?"
What are you here for Lee Newton?
Lee: I just followed the hand basket I was
in.
Anthony: Lee is here for the next few days
and Laci Green is over at Sourcefed.
Lee, where is the Sourcefed?
Lee: It's at youtube.com/sourcefed.
Go say hi to Laci.
Anthony: There you go.
And subscribe here for more Dnews.